to welcome everybody to a truly papa
blessed episode of the h3 podcast we are
joined today by perhaps the most iconic
figure in the h2 h3 universe eight years
in the making
none other than Papa John himself and
the studio welcome and thank you welcome
thank you so I mean I am a um frankly I
can't believe I'm sitting sitting across
from you right now
who ever feel is a ritual so you you had
mentioned to me that you you had thought
of reaching out to me but Papa Papa John
Gorrie correct there's a corporate we're
not we're not savvy yeah I've been
wanting to talk with you for about eight
years you're hard to get hold of frankly
but I kind of try to get a little bit I
don't know yeah but I think they're just
a little more conservative I've always
thought this to be a lot of fun I hope I
was right
yeah yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be
great it's gonna be a pizza journey
well now that you're no longer beholding
to corporate so are you in a way is this
a big middle finger to them now that
we're doing this no not at all and I'm
probably Papa John's biggest fan you
know I'm up even now
I love pizza and I love people and the
people at Papa John's are the ones that
made that company great you know you you
build 5,000 stores out of a broom closet
and you gotta do that with great people
but no franchisees I love them boys I
love them and we're pulling for well I'm
their biggest fans we love the
franchisees we hate the mortar directors
I mean I won't put the words in your
mouth but I'll say it for all those here
those sons of [ __ ] are they but they
got to be scared that you're on here now
I mean you got documents with pizza
literally pie charts you got a pie charm
with a pie on the right word I you know
we we felt like the some decisions being
made the last couple year
were not exactly in the best interest of
the system there's nothing that's
happened with Papa John's the last 20 or
30 months that wasn't predictable and
it's not been good with that being said
they're struggling and we're hoping that
things get better and they'll pull
themselves out of this mess do you want
to go back do you want to be the CEO on
the directors no I don't want to be CEO
you want to get back on the board no no
let's let it run its course let's see
what happened let's see what's gonna
happen I mean so far it's not been good
the thing that scares me the most is
there's nobody on the board or really in
leadership that has any pizza experience
right the pizza category right there's
no experience and very very dangerous
everybody wants to do pizza everybody
thinks they want to be in the pizza
business but it's a it's a really a
different animal I mean it's it's tough
I mean it really got to know the
business when you say they're dangerous
you do mean that they're what do you
mean by that well you know when you make
good decisions good things happen and
you know people prosper when you make
bad decisions just you know bad things
happen and the last 24 months for me to
sit back and watch what's happened to
the franchisees and watch happen the
employees got to call Friday we had a
young lady Robyn Kennedy been with the
company 25 years boom just out the door
two weeks ago five days before Christmas
give or take a Rob Porter been with the
company 28 years boom out the door no
notice so when you're trying to build a
culture because we're really not in the
pizza business were more in the people
business so when you're Bill trying to
build a culture that really promotes
creativity and ownership and pride and
you do things like that it kinda ruins
counterproductive there's so much ground
to talk to cover we've got the pizza
conspiracy we've got the media company
that apparently extorted you and the
company
but let me start from the top do I call
you papa
what do people call you papa my mom what
about your friends and family do they
call you papa yes everyone calls you
papa yes and so when y'all when you
become Papa well that was interesting
because we started doing the ads about
the turn of the century some twenty
years ago and we had the shirt tucked in
and suit and tie and all that but people
thought I was an actor and right yeah
they didn't think I was a real person
right
and so we Jordan Zimmerman with the Z
group came up with Papa's in the house
in the house the boots all that and then
then it became you know Papa John's and
then it became Papa and then about four
or five years ago I actually had to
change my name from John Schneider which
is German to Papa John so we actually
changed the name oh you are popular it's
like on your identity like ID what do
you mean it's just changed on the
perception and the persona brand cuz
nobody knows not her
so John John is just stayin alias John
no I am John your Papa John yeah that's
where they came up with the name John
roommate in college Ball State
University he knew my name is Johnny
came up for the name Papa I promised him
a pizza week for the rest of his life
did he get it he never came forward how
can you be fifth floor LaFollette 1982
you come up with the name Papa John when
there was no stores we build 5200 stores
and he's still having hard to claim that
Pete's yeah and if you're out there I
owe him a pizza week for the rest of his
life
so take 10 bucks a week okay it's 500
bucks a year times 35 years is seventeen
thousand five hundred dollars worth of
pizza so if you think - yeah I think you
may be assuming that someone wants to
eat well if you come forward I give him
the cash yeah or the cat so you called
you Papa before you even had kids you
had nothing to do with anything
we had the recipes we had the layout we
had
equipment we had everything but a name
hmm and he's a door mate fifth floor
LaFollette that great exhale and he
comes up with it and he puts it Papa
John and print and I we were print
driven business back in those days
because it was all coupons and I fell in
love with the name Papa John's and that
I'm and so were you did you go buy Papa
ever since you opened your first store
like let me ask you this you you you I
know you're recently divorced you were
married for a long time yeah how many
years were you married 32 and I what was
she calling you Papa no never call me
Papa called you John yeah she called the
job guys she never called you pop by the
I had a boat one time that wasn't a big
bones like 19 feet that are called Papa
that's our lease I can remember the
phrase Papa I guess the kids call you
Papa that makes sense you are their papa
yeah your boys call you Papa yeah they
always you ever think to start maybe a
second business mama mama Johnny's
that's very interesting so I'll call you
papa
you ever get any kickback is it
disrespectful to call you John no no
you're okay being called John yes oh
okay I just not sure cuz you prefer Papa
though that's just what they call really
it's like the one name anomaly like Bono
or right edge the edge just good rock
Kid Rock yeah rock right that's not his
name yeah yeah this is not or though
they get rid of the snotter
that's hard there's a role it took me
years even I used to call you s'matter
Shatner that Schnatter yeah Papa John
Pappajohn yeah so alright I understand
you are going through a divorce are you
okay how's everything
I mean was that a long time ago was that
recent four months Wow yes is it as bad
as they say it is she's a wonderful
person but I mean the divorce itself no
I think it's it's
both of us wanted it how long and so it
I think it's been best for both of us
are you feeling relieved are you feeling
do you it's gotta get like well okay
are you dating is pop out there like
you've been your single keep the money
you're healthy you look good you're
you're in good shape
slowly but surely ah I wonder if there's
any like if girls might be into like
role playing with you where they like
like you play the poppers call me daddy
call me Papa just idea giving you an
[Laughter]
interesting would you want someone that
is let's say in the pizza category
outside of the pizza Warren I don't know
if you really can pick you know I think
you if you just go out look for certain
attributes you know I don't think
that'll that'll work I think it'll just
have to happen yeah
or do you meet women well you don't if
you're me yeah do you do like social
events do you go out I like to go to bed
early and wake up early so does your a
grind your CEO you built this incredible
company are you you must be having
trouble meeting women you've been on
tinder what I gotta say you up with a
nice girl yeah I know we have we do this
parody of The Bachelor honors oh you're
quite an eligible bachelor it would be a
hell of a season I assume you're not
interested I got to tell you no we're
gonna talk about this but it's kind of
interesting but I'll take the dating
from here okay you have an age limit
now that
you're single age limit with with the
women would you data like what's your
what's your age cutoff now that you're
single I've never thought of that
cuz you know a lot of guys let's just
say you know and I don't blame them
they're out there they're single you're
wealthy you're looking good you get up
there get some strange ass but some guys
say I'm gonna I'm gonna cut it off at I
don't know twine 30:35
I don't know what do you have a cut-off
have you thought about that I think you
could meet somebody that's probably 45
or 50 that X and is active enough to be
like 30 sure you could and you could
probably meet somebody 30 or 35 and act
like they're 45 or 50 I think it depends
on the programs on the person I think
absolutely that's true that's a good
answer papa
safe answer oh good I know that if my I
know if my dad left my mom he would
probably day to 18 year old and I I just
know it he's a pig
and I love my dad well yeah I love my
dad do you think it runs in the family I
try my best I gotta tell you I grew up
with a very perverted dad and I've tried
my best to subvert those feelings but if
he if he if he was you and single give
you V B he's getting weird and wild up
but I have a feeling you're you're good
but it's not good he's not still away in
your month that's true
thank you my dad appreciates you saying
you are from you live in Kentucky are
you like a local celebrity out there in
Kentucky people got to know like a papa
you get shouts like that out here you
know Louisville is probably where I get
left alone the most ting because it's
not a big deal yeah they just look at
John the pizza maker Jenny loves making
peace and down a community leader you
know a good corporate citizen I don't
really think Louisville probably get
left alone more than anywhere else in
the world maybe when you walk around
like New York or LA I don't know how
often you do you probably get recognized
a lot you got a face on on the pizza box
used to yeah I mean
Latin America very partly Latin America
like China I might as well be on Mars
oh yeah no yeah la New York a little
less but it's actually gotten more the
last the last five or ten years in the
Midwest you know where Papa John's is
really rock solid for sure you're sure
you're a superstar out there probably
superstar but they go oh the pizza guy
beats yeah give them a $10 off car take
a picture and then oh that's where you
walk around with gift cards oh yeah
that's crowd-pleaser I love that yeah
and it's it's really cool because you
got one for me I can get you a pizza ha
ha ha
don't tell corporate there's a tree of
the biggest house in Kentucky
I read that online I don't know if it's
the biggest it's probably one of the
biggest one of the biggest yeah I love
my home in Kentucky has been good to
Papa
pieces though the whole thing's been a
blessing I've got so many people to be
thankful for that you know supported me
and gave me a lot of encouragement early
on when I didn't have anything I can't
tell you how many times I thought we
were gonna go broke and people just
really were there in my corner and so
but it's it's been a great ride with a
great group of folks the original
employee number one still works for me
oh really what position are then well
she Denise Robinson it was a she was a
cook and daddy hired her as a cook for
seven bucks a day and I said we got a
cook cuz dad now we're kind of you know
jack of all trades master of none and
it's a great and he goes there's one
problem I said what's that daddy he said
well she can't cook she can't cut you
out of cooking this is back when we
didn't have seven bucks a day to blow
mm-hmm
but she had a great attitude and dad
taught me early on hire for attitude and
train train for aptitude that's Jill
she's done she's been with us and she's
great you go what you do yeah she's 36
she does whatever she wants really so
does she have your back now in this oh
yeah you've still got your allies oh and
Papa's house yeah it's not all it's not
all uh
it's act it's been great I mean it
really has been its to go through this
it's a fascinating experience it's a
learning experience and it's it's it's
educational I just wish it wasn't me you
know me going through it but you know we
had a very comfortable life you know the
company was making 150 million bucks a
year Island you know 31 percent of it no
debt great pizza great product great
great great everything and and so you
know and then this this well let's talk
about it let's let's let's talk okay
you did an interview let's start here in
November and what you famously claimed
you have eaten over 40 pizza and 30 days
now first of all that went sensational
viral what was your reaction to that
well I didn't say that eaten 40 pizzas
in 30 days I said I had we're gonna
split here yeah I went when I said I had
a pizza that means I ate it well when I
said had a pizza means I'm inspecting
right so I'm I'm not eating every pizza
I may be eating parts of pizzas how many
pizzas you eat on a weekly basis I
probably eight or nine slices a week
Brett when I was at Papa John's I was
probably 12 or 15 cuz we're always
tested new products that's awesome yeah
oh I love a new exercise a lot yeah good
yeah ski cuz I but you know pizza is
actually very nutritious
very healthy you just can't eat a bunch
of it yeah I mean it's really great that
sounds like pizza propaganda well it's
325 calories of sliced three empty it's
like I don't yeah slices your golden
eats not me having slices and your
garlic butter golden like myself when
did the garlic but you know what let's
let's stick to the
you got on an Instagram that's how we
got in touch what prompted you to make
an Instagram account were you feeling
the viral sensation of the Papa the Papa
come back
Papa Redemption arc yeah I think again
the the board in leadership is probably
leans to be a little more conservative
and the social media platforms I think
scared them and so they they kind of
kept me away from that that Avenue and
we hired the new PR firm proactive up in
DC mark serrano on his team and they
hired Matthew and Jordan out of
Indianapolis and they said you know give
it a try on us it up I'll try it but if
it turns negative and it's it's nasty I
don't want them to do with it but you
know it's being to it right it's been
doing that months it's been cool it's
awesome yeah on something else well you
know what happens someone sent us a tip
to like I think this is Papa John's real
Instagram and we're like there's no way
we don't believe it we'll turn it to a
whole story arc for us where we slowly
realize it was your actually your your
account look like when you say that they
didn't want you to have an Instagram
account let's say like is it an actual
conversation a meeting where you meet
with a team and they all have an input
on what they think you should do well
the our generation didn't grow up with
with social media and you can understand
in 1995 which would have been what 25
years ago we didn't have computers in
the store we were operating down to
cigar boxes with deli sheets so we had
to go through the wave of technology
just to have POS and then the internet
came along and we had you know right
exactly remember the video well
announcing that we did really well on
the POS in that transition and we were
first to the market on the internet so
we did well but then the social media
came along and I don't think anybody in
the building and you know our age
demographics understood it right so by
not understanding it I think we kind of
frayed away from it you know but the
it's a risk roared it is and fire well
coming on the show today there's there's
upside there's down
and so you know but anything that's
worth doing is gonna have a risk that's
the pop I know that's true
well I freaked I'm so glad you're here
because to me
I'm it's very brave of you to come in
here with us but I do think that it it's
just so incredible for you to have the
courage to come in here and talk to us
in this format that I think most people
in your situation under the advice of
all the their handlers would would would
just totally shy away but this is the
most genuine way for you to get your
message out right and so I think that
that this is a great step for Papa yeah
and but in all sincerity the you've been
a Papa John's fan no yeah and you get
your wife here and I just felt somewhat
safe I mean I know there's gonna be
parts of interview that like the segment
we just left we're you know final I
didn't know he was gonna go there but I
knew that coming in get worse oh so now
you're making it sound like it's not
that bad with you and the Papa John
corporate but they removed the mention
of you on their website look here on the
television about us they act like you
never didn't even exist they go there
first of all they're making rewriting
history this ain't Papa stands for
people our priority always you seen this
and then they say they go it was founded
in a broom closet in Jeffersonville not
no mention of you
well what's misleading that it says it's
the foundation we started and the one
who's we so I mean that's kind of that's
gotta feel bad I mean this is your baby
this is your life's work Papa the
rewrite they can't they won't even say
give you the credit of having your own
name well not to correct you but Papa
always meant people are priority one
always we've always realized from the
get-go you have to take care of your
people first that's always been your
that's that's been it so that's not
misleading that's no it's not but the
name that they don't mention that that
whose broom closet that belonged to him
well they have taken the position that I
never existed
yeah and they have research that says
half the people out there associate me
with the brand or that
and a half not 5% of 10% so I don't know
we've kind of studied what corporates
done it hasn't worked out too well
nobody this is what I call a lose lose
lose lose and one of my fundamental
principles and business is everybody has
to win suppliers and franchisees
employees communities have to win and
this has been a lose lose lose lose but
I don't know how you pretend like the
founder didn't exist when he's alive and
well he's right here and he's papa he's
and it's authentic it's the truth we've
we did this the hard way we did this the
long way and we build it one store at a
time up to 5,000 stores of a broom
closet I'm not sure how you erase that
and if you do erase it I think you do
part of the population the wrong way
exactly so the corporation has put
themselves in a position that their
conflict is our decision-making well I
would I call it corporate genius
corporation you would call corporate
idiots but I got it for the lawyers I
gotta call corporate gene-gene okay you
got it
hmm it seems that they they must have
made a calculated decision that they
thought cutting you out after all the
controversies would have helped the
company on decline that's what I assumed
was there was there logic but I put a
lot of not stupid - well that's that's
where we there's a fundamental
disconnect between my beliefs and I
think the corporate geniuses I think I
don't think you could fool people maybe
once twice but I think people are smart
the fact that the corporate geniuses
think they can fool people now that's
that's what birds even people that are
like disagree with you or like outraged
by the controversies they know the
puppet it's still God papa john's and
then everyone who's one ride-or-die Papa
John's is pissed it's bad what do you
think about the Papa Dilla I mean were
you involved in this no would you ever
greenlight such a such a abomination of
God they obviously have research that I
don't have yeah it is research you don't
like street smarts right yeah you got it
well let's play it out Papa John's Pizza
no no Papa John's Pizza quesadilla no no
no Papa John's Pizza quesadilla Papa
diya no no Papa John Pizza quesadilla
Papa dia lousy calzone just call it a
calzone instead of making it sound like
it's not a quesadilla that that is I
don't ride it yes what do you think go
ahead speak the truth I mean it's it's a
nice side item being nice you're being
nice here I can tell coming in gloves
off but goes off with you not clothes
off of the court you're being you're
being nice here's my problem I've got
I've got franchisees out there that I
love and write I can't I can't say
negative I would not have put my all my
eggs in that basket that's for sure the
Papa dela poppity pop idea yeah all
right well then let's talk about the
people that like you claimed in your now
famous interview that there was a
conspiracy to out you as the board of
directors that it was completely
fabricated what was recounted of your
racist language on the phone call and
you've claimed that those who
perpetrated this conspiracy against you
should be in jail do you or do you still
stand by those statements well let's go
the less you know as a shareholder you
really can't put a Board of Directors in
jail now you can take their homes if
they violated the duty of loyalty and
duty of care which they have on multiple
cases so we'll see how that plays out in
the courts but you can't really as a
show to put them in jail
okay well anyway I understand you're
just you're just speaking at a matter of
speech but the conspiracy the
fabrication these are people at the
highest level of the company who have
conspired to ruin your life and in short
right do you agree with that statement I
do agree with that statement mmm and so
the is this the day of reckoning you
spoke about well the day it well if
you're a franchisee or an employer that
we just talked about two of them
twenty years ago thirty five years god
bless I mean yeah that's the day of
reckoning when you lose you know your
career and it was your job franchisees I
mean they are you know this is very
painful for me to watch
we had you've seen that the trajectory
on sales and profit and now you've seen
a crash oh yeah
that's very hard for me to sit back with
my hands tied no matter how much money I
spend or how what I try to do to help
them my hands are tied
you know I'm no longer running the ship
so it's hard to watch this because when
you built the machine and you have
people around you that help build the
machine you know cause and effect you
know trial and error and and you watch
some of the things that are going on
with people that have never been in the
business and you watch people get hurt
I mean hurt bad that's that sleepless
nights and there's a lot of those yeah
you referred to a day of reckoning for
the board of directors what what did we
mean what does the wreck what is the
reckoning I heard I heard rumors that
the phone call the notorious phone call
for example you got a copy of that is
that true yes what question won't me
answer first so do you have the
recording yes does it exonerate you yes
oh yeah can we hear it I don't know if
you can hear it I can tell you what it
says okay you need to look at the hope
that what happened tell me about that
conversation the when this went down on
the 11th the company where myself didn't
have the tape laundry service had the
tape the company got the tape within 10
days the call but they wouldn't let me
hear the call the tape until the next
year February of nineteen so I was
pretty sure what I said and I know my
heart I know how I feel about this issue
I wasn't real worried about what I'd
said because I wouldn't say anything
that was going to put any of us in
jeopardy what I said was I never used
the word mm-hmm but you used the word I
said Colonel Sanders used the word like
did you use the N word I said Colonel
Sanders use the N word yes
I had never used that word yeah but we
had the word I said the word
yeah you said and I said what into the
word yes what the little in a in a
confidential meeting with that agency
that was supposed to be setting me up to
protect this very thing so the meeting
was to make sure something like this
didn't happen so they should have said
to you well papa
you shouldn't even when you're referring
to the word
you shouldn't say the word but what they
did as I understand it is they recorded
this call that was meant to be for
racial sensitivity training cry and
leaked it is that I feel a little worse
than that they they see who leaked it we
don't know that's why we filed the
lawsuit
wow-whee laundry service in their
response said they didn't leak it mm-hmm
but Forbes got the data for somewhere I
don't know if they got it from Papa
John's I don't know if they got it from
an executive Oh Papa John's we're not
sure who was on that call was well like
I guess someone on the call was
recording it yes we didn't know the
court the recall was being recorded
that's a bad news it was secretly
recorded the good news is they recorded
the call you know because what I said
was not anything you anti-racist youyou
I understand you said you use the n-word
but you used it in the context of
explaining that you're not racist well
although can you see that some people
would be offended that you would use the
word at all
I for I've gotten into the that that's
very issue myself and and I I can see
where they're coming from in that that
when you even when you use the n-word
and the context of saying oh I would
never say that but you said it you did
say it when you were saying I would
never say it yeah the thing about the
call the call was like fifty minutes
fifty fifty and the call was extremely
positive about in my position the
history how was brought up on you know
anti race period there's no tolerance
for it in my family in my upbringing and
the it finally came up again at the end
I said listen so-and-so uses the word I
never used the word let's get off the
word they recorded it he thought there
was trying to set you up they kept
trying to get you to say the word yeah I
think I'm saying I do I think they were
trying to agitate me hmm what did they
say it agitator
they just keep pushing and pushing even
they kept bringing up the comments that
were made back in November on the NFL
conference call which there's nothing in
that call that's even even sort of
provocative the franchisees ahead of
franchise the Association will tell you
that was an oculus it was benign and yet
they stirred that up and somehow painted
that into the the race corner and the
company didn't do anything to defend
that or to straighten that out or to
point out that it was mischaracterized
so that was kind of the first clue that
the you know like hey they're going to
go down this road you've got to make
sure we have a plan in place to prevent
this from getting getting out of hand by
being not truthful and that's what
happened so did you have when you were
on this call it sounds like you now
perceive it to be the intention of that
call was to incriminate you not to train
you
well if you if you look at how do you at
the time I had 31% of the company how
how do you ask the founder Papa John
from his own company and there's really
no way to get that done except paint me
in the race corner and what the company
learned with the Obama care in the NFL
comments is if they did nothing social
media in itself would take me to that
spot which was a very bad spot and it
just gave them an excuse to to get rid
of me but why would they want to get rid
of you because now that you're gone
nobody
I mean clearly nobody could anybody have
benefited now at this point from you
being gone
nobody has benefit it's back to it's a
lose lose lose and I think until this
gets clarified and the public can digest
really what happened I think it's gonna
have consequences on on Papa John's
business health but let me finish the
the company when you're good at
something you make it look easy and we
just had a really good team and we've
been doing this for 35 years it's kind
of like doing what you all do you just
know what you're doing and you're good
at it
we had a board and leadership the
thought okay we can run a lot better
without John and you know it's it's
intoxicating
I mean 150 million bucks here Papa
John's hello Pat on the building all
that it's in talks
okay ting and power and control and
greed is alive of well in corporate
America so their mindset was let's get
rid of John do your pointless pretend
like he never existed let's take his
take the company over they had a bunch
of self-interest each individual had
different self-interest with different
characteristics of taking the business
over and we'll just take it over and
life will be be grand without him so you
think it was a conspiracy by the entire
Board of Directors I don't exactly know
right we've tried twice we had a
lawsuits call them to 20 but basically
it's a lawsuit to get the documents the
company hasn't given us any documents
what kind of documents would you I want
their emails much like a subpoena
protects we won that ruling you did we
did win there so how does the court
enforce it when they refuse it has not
been enforced yeah and the Chancellor
called for shard and he's a guy wouldn't
want to mess with frankly and for him to
rule in our favor to get those documents
and yet the board has handed over no
documents I wouldn't want to be in the
board seat and then we filed a second
lawsuit with laundry service and that's
simply to get to the bottom of get to
the truth the day of reckoning as you
say what happened here how did they do
this and I think what you're going to
find is the different levels there was a
different agendas and different goals
the folks at corporate had one goal keep
their jobs get John's money you know be
the C then the board had another goal
they want to be chairman we had one
board member I had a conflict he took
over the marketing etc etc and then
you've got laundry service which was
Wasserman and Goodell and they had
another agenda which is probably to shut
me up and to take the company you're
Julius Caesar's you're the pizza and and
and guy what was the name of your hand
pet Richie Richie wasn't was Brutus was
that is that a good analogy did he stab
you in the back that's quite the best
analogy I've heard over it no doubt
about it
Wow yeah no doubt about it it's that was
painful I mean Steve had been with the
company 20 years hired him at six bucks
an hour last year he made six million
dollars
and then he you know pulls a stunt like
this but you know that's something he's
gonna have to live with and you haven't
spoken to him at all no what would you
say to him if you saw him oh gosh what
would I say to him um I don't think I'd
have to say anything I think I would
just he knows how does one look at him
he he knows how disappointing them any
mean he knows how disappointed there he
is with himself he let Steve Rios bad I
don't know but this guy hurt a lot of
people we mentioned too but literally
thousands of people have gotten hurt by
Steve Ritchie's selfishness and ambition
and disregard for the team and other
people but the guys hurt a lot of people
mm-hmm so much intrigue to an unravel
there's so much interest at play
on trail but yeah yeah portrayals must
be exhausting and you're at the center
of it it's very Shakespearean do you
feel like you're in the middle of a
Shakespearean play you know betrayal is
an interesting on that scale that yeah
makes it's like I said it's fascinating
it's an education I just wish it would
me do you ever wonder why you I mean
what did you do to to incite such
betrayal I mean do you do you find
yourself wondering how maybe what how
could this happen I mean what do you
think about that well you know Papa
John's is the American dream and when
you look at power control greed envy you
have that in spades the you know failure
is in what some ways easier than success
because you know everybody wants a piece
of success and Papa John's was the
pinnacle you know Papa John's Pizza
American dream third big pizza chain in
the world yeah and I think that makes
things more tempting for people to get
intoxicated again and to do silly things
but but to answer a question I thought
this could happen and I prepared for it
physically intellectually and
analytically
well you have to be to go through what
you've gone through the last 20 months
you better be on your game you better be
rock solid because you know it's you're
taking a lot of you're taking a lot of
shots and so you've got to you got to
take care of yourself you can take care
you look healthy you and therapy no
probably should be but no should be are
you embarrassed to to talk to a
therapist no no I've talked to their
photographer I think I think you I think
you need a good therapist yeah you know
times like this and you got a good dog
with you who I just met yeah um but I
knew this could happen I thought how
long were you suspecting you feel it if
you're if you're an entrepreneur you
feel you sense things you sense the
iceberg in front of you miles and miles
before everybody else does so I knew
this but I thought it would come from
the outside in I thought it'd be a
hostile takeover somebody you know
coming in and doing something crazy I
didn't know it would be from the inside
you know I didn't know that the people
on the inside were capable of doing
something like you didn't anticipate
what really and here's why people always
act in their self best interests and
this the way they've gone about this
like John or don't like John the way
they've gone about this has hurt a lot
of people it's hurt my employees hurt by
franchisees suppliers this has not been
a win for anybody and I knew if they did
something like this would this would be
bad for them because it's stupid
this really is stupid I mean if you're
gonna get rid of the founder do it over
a period of time
don't taking you know outside kick him
to the street and one day over something
he didn't say I mean they manufactured
this and then they did that did they
what they did but I didn't realize that
they weren't intelligent enough to
realize that by doing what they were
doing they were actually hurting
everybody else I missed that piece let
me go back to the to the I'm just so
intrigued by the phone call because when
we go back to the phone call on that
fateful day everything happened so fast
right like I read that on the same day
that the phone it was it the same day
the phone call happened that you were
removed from the
from the Board of Directors no the how
much time passed the phone call happened
on May the 22nd mm-hmm
Richie fired the agency laundry service
on the media side the next day and I
went what are you doing I mean because
they're gonna think that I fired him
they had a tough conversation with the
CEO of laundry service that Friday and
then two weeks later the owner Casey
Wasserman of laundry service called and
said if you don't give us six million
dollars we're going to bury your founder
because we taped the call so Wow
so they tried to extort the money Papa
John's didn't give in to that demand and
then since Papa John's didn't give the
guy that six million they went public
with it on July the 11th so a couple
things there first of all there was a
pretty good time distance still between
the make all May the 23rd and July the
11th and second of all Papa John's board
or management didn't do anything to make
sure that the founder and the brands
functions were protected back Papa
John's did too just the opposite when
the caught when the when all this hit
Forbes Papa John's piled on instead of
defending there's no why did Richie fire
the media company the day after the call
I think again he used me as an escape
code to say well the reason we fired is
because John didn't want you around
which is you know nothing to do with
that but Sid was he privy to what was on
the call he was on the call oh he was on
the call so it was was there outrage
expressed where people offended on the
call though or after the call it was all
gravy so why would he have the presence
of mind to fire them the next day I just
don't understand like what was his
justification being like it will had
nothing to do with the call when he
fired them or dead the I think the folks
in mark and he realized that laundry
service was the rat wrong firm too by
the media and so Richie just kind of
used as an excuse to do something he
should have done anyway okay so I could
speculate it was unrelated to the call
I'll be speculating okay yeah yeah so he
fires them and then and then how much
time passed before they blackmail the
company it's a week or two that's when
they demanded the six billion Casey
Wasserman Rickman said he was
belligerent on the phone if he didn't
get his six million you know with a name
like laundry service you guys could have
been more skeptical it sounds like
they're laundering money
it sounds shaded if again when the
laundry service but I'm assuming this is
a big reputable media company what does
it mean to buy media okay in marketing
there's at least two disciplines with
social media maybe a third one is you
actually create the ads creative and
shoot the ads the second is you have the
money to run the ads the creative is
maybe a six seven million dollar year
account the media buys maybe an 80 or 90
million dollar a year account and that
was called going through them yes so
they were they were there was a lot of
money going through them they there was
a lot at stake by firing them they were
losing a lot of money yes it's a little
bit worse than that because laundry
service had hired a lot of people
thinking they were going to get the
media side of the business that's my
understanding
oh so they had invested heavily in Papa
John's and then when they were fired
you think it provoked them because they
would put them in a very rough position
I don't know a lot about this because I
wouldn't involve but I do know that they
were worse than provoked they were they
were very upset that they didn't they
lost the media and so then they come a
week later and say pay us six million
bucks which I'm just going to assume is
what they spent preparing or something
maybe and there if I'm just trying to
justify their actions you're like you
know we spent six million dollars in
Papa John and you pulled the plug on us
so pay us the money or we're going to or
release this tape of the founder and
instead of they so Papa John's doesn't
pay now did you know that they were
threatening a company because you were
on the board of directors at a time
Richie was the CEO so did you know that
they were threatening the company was
that public knowledge among the board
yes yeah yeah yeah we knew that and were
you scared I mean what was your
responded I didn't like the whole
situation oh yeah because I had a lot of
involvement with all your service I
like the fact that Ritchie had fired him
the day after the call right I didn't
like the fact they taped the call secret
to live and then oh yeah in fact when
they told me that they want six million
dollars or they're gonna bury the
founder they have a tape actually went
thank God they got a tape the tape will
protect me because I knew what I said
was not that was a good tape for me
because it was a very positive meeting
but all this manly it doesn't matter
because nobody's heard the tape and
damage has been done
well laundry service doesn't want
anybody damage has been done
yeah yeah oh my god yeah the tape
exonerates me I mean you have the tape I
don't have the tape you do not have the
tape yeah I already said that you have
heard it I've not heard the tape you're
not but I have people that represent me
that have heard the tape the tape helps
me okay I wish the tape was made public
yeah me you know because Papa John's and
laundry service do not want that tape
public because it's gonna it's going to
depict a whole different picture and
what was depicted with Forbes in the
media so how was it reported first that
laundry service came to you guys with
this tape and said pay us 6 million or
we're gonna release it how did you first
hear about that Ritchie Ritchie told you
he called you he called me I was his
theory we went in arson yes in his
office you see if Ritchie knew Carolyn
Euler that had the G C legal counsel
knew and then the board would have known
that Wasserman one at six million
dollars or he was going to bury us now
we old at the time we old laundry
service between a man and a half and two
and half million so we did own some
money I don't want to say the six
million was you know blackmail
necessarily it was it was it was
exciting how is it not so I mean
extortion is illegal so how is it that
you guys weren't able to press charges
against them
why would Papa John's put me in that
situation why would they not call the
FBI right why well that you gotta call
the yeah sorted you know your founders
on the line and they're paying him in a
box that he something he didn't say and
he's not and in at the same time once it
comes public on a false narrative then
they bury me farther hmm so the question
is well pop it was Papa John's and on
this yes
was Richie and the Shapiro and on this
yes but that's an event but remember I'm
hammering on Goodell I'm telling the the
Goodell to get his act together so whose
get delegate bells the Commissioner of
the NFL oh right and I'm telling well
Goodell his personal friends Watchmen
they watch each other kids and so forth
because they do all the media buying for
the NFL
you got me hammering on Goodell get your
act together about the kneeling kneeling
I didn't say any about the kneeling I
just said to resolve this to the players
and owner satisfaction he's friends with
Washington Washington owns laundry
service so all you were pissing a lot of
people off piss a lot of people of I was
pissed off you're pissing powerful
people off Goodell for sure that and I
think the fact that we were in four
universities with a free market and
entrepreneurship that probably upset a
few folks at on that side of the
equation but I think Richie was gonna
lose this job he did right curtly wanted
to be chairman of the board Shapiro he
wanted that forty fifty million a year
in marketing that we talked about Adele
one need to go away and Washington was
pissed because he lost the media
business so I think you have a bunch of
audit of a hurricane middle of a bunch
in the look at the sediment at the time
with the public you know you have all
these movements they're going on that
are just we just fell right into it and
instead of the company being there to
help and protect the brand the
spokesperson they kind of piled on were
you not able to call the FBI yourself we
did we have called the FBI the FBI is
looking at this but I mean you got to
have cooperation from but from corporate
and from laundry rooms that's why we
filed a lawsuit the lawsuit will get a
lot of discovery a lot of the things
that the day of reckoning the truth will
come out and fall suit I'm fascinated by
this first meeting with Richie when you
sat down in there What did he say I'm
just I'm so interested by that when at
the time you thought he was a friend
it was a lie we'll keep this pretty
high-level move quick on this but the
meaning was supposed to be a meeting on
the creative because they were going to
put me back in the ads they took me out
of theirs from September October
up till down we're talking you know June
July timeframe
maybe May but we were going to go back
in the edge and so we went back in the
edge we wanted to make sure on a PR
front we were ready in case that the
race card came out because of the
kneeling controversy the meeting was
supposed to be on creative the other
aspect of marketing so I walked in
thinking it was a creative meeting and
the first thing they put down is a sheet
of paper how many people were there five
or six okay board members
no not just executive assistant was
there Ritchie was there okay guy named
Joseph Stein for laundry service okay oh
so he was there yeah
what was he doing there if he was
threatening you well that was Wasserman
that member that's after two weeks after
that all right
but what okay go ahead May the 27th of
my original conference call not day not
that threatening oh that's okay so so we
got a meeting on the May of the 22nd we
think it's a marketing meeting okay
and it turns in to be the first they put
down a deckhand said the first question
is are you a racist and I'm like whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa weird I know it's a
setup
go ahead no i'm fascinated they say are
you a race are you a racist and I looked
around I'm gonna what word of this I
thought we were going to talk about
creative hmm and he said no we're going
to talk about you know anything to do
with race and PR in this meeting because
you're gonna go to Chicago Sunday for
some interviews and I said well who else
how long have you all known we were
gonna do this meeting hmm and they said
well about day and a half or two days I
said well why didn't you all give me the
agenda you were irritated from I was
irritated for yeah because they they
pull a fast one art from the get-go so
they're just trying to agitate agitate
agitate what other kind of questions on
there I mean that's a hell of a way to
start is are you a racist Wow yeah and
how and and the call was for 50 minutes
long 50 minutes and what other kind of
questions you recall if I'm asking
upbringing how was raised you know it
wasn't really sensitivity they were they
were prodding yes and did you get a
sense that there was something off about
the meeting
I never got comfortable with the meaning
but to the point where I was a little
bit careful about my responses because I
didn't you know I didn't feel good about
it but yeah in the comment at the end
nobody thought anything of it you know
hey y'all gonna knock this off from
Sanders calls black people inward I
never used that word so let's just start
in their mind they're like we got bets
without the I think you're right
Wow and so fast-forward a week later
when you walk into Ritchie's office and
he tells you that the company's being
extorted what was that meeting like I go
what do you mean and he said the guy was
going off the deep end he was
belligerent that was the word for it to
use that's why is he belligerent he goes
he wants at 6 million dollars because
he's got a tape that says you know you
said the n-word I said well I didn't say
the word the context I said you know I
never say that word and I said the tapes
gonna help us Steve and then so from you
know the end of May 1st of June to the
first week of July they try to get it
resolved so they were gonna the lawyers
are going back and forth mm-hmm so I
guess he didn't get resolved until the
end of the end of July this so so when
they decide to make it public what did
they they never actually released the
tape they just made a like a an
announcement but what did they announce
because that the tape has never been
released so what actually did they say
when I got off the aircraft coming back
from Columbus Ohio on the 10th 5 o'clock
Carolyn Euler called being said who was
that the GC at Papa John's mm-hmm and
because she was trying to get the matter
resolved or so she said with laundry
service she said the head of HR for
laundry service is talking to Forbes
about the use of the n-word and that's
the first notice I got in a couple hours
in Arts Inc yeah I win oh gosh here we
go yep it was I mean I but I didn't know
that the people on the inside that I
thought were protecting me were actually
setting all this up and then Forbes
called at8 said we're
run this article do you want to comment
I said well let me see the article said
well you don't get to see it you see in
the paper tomorrow morning at 5:30 and
next day advise you leave a comment
no I didn't get to see the article right
I didn't you know I didn't know where
they were headed you regret not getting
a comment no because I had no idea what
was going on right well you knew that
there you probably knew at the time it
was gonna be Papa John said the n-word
is that what you expected no not what
you expected knowing what I've known
through the NFL before when I said let's
settle this between the owners and the
player satisfaction and they turn that
into race I knew that it was a very
dangerous position for me to be in I
knew this was not good I did not know my
own company in an agency who was hired
to keep this from happening we were in
on this to actually make it worse not
better so you were you shocked when you
read the article in the morning um I was
shocked at the headlines and right you
know I was like wow I remember the
headlines what they said they the
headline played up the use of the n-word
it made it sound like that I'd called
somebody right word it's just Papa John
used the n-word
they made it accusatory nature when what
I said was I don't use that word so
let's not use that word in fact if I go
to dinner and somebody uses that word
one time
don't say the word and I'll get up and
leave dinner I literally would and I've
done that more than once but it's just
not a good word so don't use the word I
don't use the word I'm you you how many
times you uh I guess and can I've never
been at dinner with somebody who's the
n-word I don't know if it's an area
happened yeah but it's a it's a
different lay the land yeah I think
people I mean in LA I guess people are
more conscious but you think there's
still a lot of racism out there in your
parts no I don't think it's prevalent
but sometimes you get some others had a
few things get a little sloppy it's like
it's not cool yeah yeah yeah I feel you
if it was part of the
vocabulary they wouldn't be somebody I
associate with anyway yeah right but
some people think it's cute or funny or
way try to the edge yeah and it's not
yeah so the headline comes out it's
shocking the the shock back and the
media is is immediate yes and and we're
and I as I understand it correct me if
I'm wrong you were removed from board of
directors that very day
no resigned is the chairman you resigned
was that how does that look because of
were you al stood I mean or you resigned
almost the difference the I don't wanna
get too technical but this is corporate
governance the shareholders vote the
Board of Directors in mmm-hmm so to get
a board of director removed to takes a
shareholder vote we didn't have a
shareholder vote in at the time I had 31
percent that would have been in tough to
get rid of me as a board of directors
the Board of Directors vote on who's the
chairman the Board of Directors asked me
to step down as chairman because of what
they felt like it would save the company
so Wednesday the 11th I'm still thinking
the Board of Directors is still in
John's camp and I had a couple meetings
with one or two directors that Thursday
or Friday I still thought the Board of
Directors was in the John camp it was
until Saturday night that he called an
emergency meeting on Sunday that oh my
gosh my own board is now going to use
this to hurt me because you know I think
the the stepping the act of stepping
down was like almost came off as an
admission of guilt I didn't have a
choice
let me have a choice well the Board of
Directors they voted you oh they would
they would a boat about if I had to step
down
I said yeah well what a nightmare that
week must have been for you mean Jessica
yeah I mean there was that that night
and then remember by this time we had
two PR experts on staff and the
Wednesday that this happened 11th was
the last time they ever talked to me so
nobody on Papa John's has ever called to
help so you got two people they're
supposed to be crisis manager in the
shitstorm and nobody from the company
suspicious
what's going on here I had hired an
agency out in LA a general 11 o'clock on
Saturday night that's what I realized we
had a problem yeah is this [ __ ]
these crisis management people cuz it I
mean the crisis wasn't managed it was
full-blown
did they help I'd say they agency that I
have today proactive is turned it around
for sure the agency we used in LA we've
used them twice and your point hasn't
been been been good for me mm-hmm but
proactive has been very good the
position we're in today versus where was
at seven months ago is nine-day we're
now on the offensive do you regret not
do you have any regrets about how it all
went down
anything you would redo over well I'll
be fine I mean you know I'll be fine the
damage done to the employees I keep
coming back to that I know in the
franchisees these people the way they
handle this and the way they went about
this and their motives have hurt a lot
of people that part keeps me up at night
there I has been nice where I laid in
bed going my gosh you know that's not
what I said and that's not what I'm
about how you know it is you know never
thought my world was going to come to an
end but it's kind of like kind of scary
because you kind of don't know how to
get yourself out of this mess
and the when you're painting in the
corner of race it's bad it's a terrible
position to be in and especially when
you're not there's been days where I
wish I'd have said something that was or
acted like I was racist because then
then you get treatment or you get help
or you say you're sorry but that's not
my nature that's not what I am as a beam
and that that's all you know how can you
say you're sorry for something there may
be correct the record like hey uh I
guess you did you expect someone to do
that for you well if the this has caused
a tremendous amount of damage the
company was making 150 million dollars a
year now makes basically zero if the
board stops
and says he's on probation mm-hmm you
know he's on the bench till we find out
what happened here they had the tape
within a week they could have said oh my
gosh
he didn't what he said was anti-racist
and it was a positive call he's not
you're not portraying this right if they
would characterize it in a truthful
manner we're out of this mess pretty
quick and they didn't instead they piled
on they dug themselves in a hole when
they realized that what I said was
nothing wrong with it they've gone so
far that they couldn't turn back and
they're there today they're in a
position where they can't turn they
can't turn back they can't take the hit
and the mistake of how they handle this
because why the shareholders and why the
well the shareholders have not filed
suit against the company because the
stocks high we'll talk more about that
later but why the franchisees m filed
suit against the company I don't know
did your personal net worth take a hit
well when I was running the company we
we were at 89 bucks a share and now I
think we're at 65 but at one time the
stock got down to 39 right oh it's you
know 39 verse 265 it's like ha I mean
it's but so the stocks actually doing
well there's a concept called private
equity and private equity is probably
the most dangerous financial instrument
ever created by mankind because it
inflates the values the pease and so
stock prices are kind of pulled being
pulled along by the private equity farce
and so Papa John's you think it's worth
much less than it's being portrayed on
the stock market Papa John's yeah how is
the company worth two billion dollars
that makes zero mm tell me I don't know
you know you know 2021 they may make 40
million bucks
you mean if they don't have any one-time
write-offs that they've had for three
years a girl they keep em one time right
off year after year which is pretty
amazed every think about just dumping
your stock now while you can
oh yeah I've had but you still have 17
percent right no I had one time I had 31
percent ten million shares and now I'm
probably closer to two or three million
shares so you've dumped a lot dumped a
lot of stock
it's my way shorten the company oh I
don't think the company's worth anywhere
near to 65 bucks a share
unless Jeff Smith who's the chairman the
board who owns a company called
starboard value unless he's found a
bigger sucker than he is to buy the
company you know 70 75 I don't think
becoming you'll stay at 65 bucks I think
the stock price is the last card in the
house of cards to fall but they may have
the company soul you know you know got
work out there you got inspired brands
Rob Lynch the CEO came from kamar B's
which was inspired brand so inspire
brands maybe you think the Arby's is
behind the pizza Dilla
do you think RVs do you think it's an
abomination of your name that they use
papa in the Papa della Papa di I didn't
feel any animosity and do you think
Arby's is behind the Papa dia I have no
reason to believe influence
why would it's the CEO of Arby's came to
Papa right yes so I'm saying that
madness the Arby's madness he's not from
the pizza category he has no pleasing
experience correct so he's coming at
Papa John's and he's pitching this crazy
nonsense like the puppet Papa diya um I
don't know about all the wall I just
know that the only way you can justify
$65 a shares if you got a buyer mmm and
so stay tuned the next 50 to 35 days see
what happens you see if inspired brains
don't coming about Papa Johnson now well
you know in by the way if you if if Jeff
Smith can find a bigger sucker than he
is then good good for him who Jeff Smith
is the chairman of starboard value now
he's here why do you say that because
the 65 bucks is Jerry
oh he's strike price is 51 and the
company's worth 2 billion dollars that
makes zero he's put money into the
company 250 million oh wow otherwise the
company was this is how bad it got the
company was in violation of their
covenants on their loans had to come in
and say the liquid injection yeah to
keep the stock price up to keep no to
keep the company running default from
the bank loans Wow yeah scary times
that guy sweatin you think no is he
sweating I don't think he's sweat I
think the Board of Directors of Papa
John's was fighting before he put in 250
million now if inspired brands work
doesn't buy this company in the next 50
to 75 days they're all glad they're all
gonna be sweatin bowling right
and the pizza won't save you if they
don't fix it yeah so I'm I want to go
back one more time to this big
conspiracy this phone call was there a
moment where you're like well you had a
moment of realization that you had been
betrayed by everybody and when was that
moment I can remember talking to our ad
agency and second-biggest franchise
March April of 18 for this happened and
going what's going on here because it
wasn't we we felt something was going on
but we didn't know the conspiracy with
Richie and Shapiro and currently we did
not know that and then Dan has just
walked into the room and disrupted
everything why are we in the room down
okay thank go ahead Dan maybe not dan
has ruined the show thank you dan dan is
angry he looked up oh thank you Dan for
being proactive but thank you Dan let me
get my thoughts together here you I was
you were talking about them you were
talking to the franchisee about the
moment you realized we we knew Richie
was a bad actor march/april of 18 the
call was the 22nd I was gonna fire
Richie in July hmm so Richie knew I was
gonna fire him so when did I realize it
was as bad as it was about a month or
two after July 11th I was because the
company every day would do something to
make it worse instead of trying to
salvage it or make it better or you know
to get the truth out there they actually
pay
kept paint me in that race corner and so
my own company was trying to even try to
fill me under the bus so that was that
was and so that a month or two after
after the it hit the wire I knew the
company was my worst enemy when did this
day the company still my worst enemy
right when it comes to the PR the Anwar
because they won't let it go they keep
trying to bring it up mm-hmm
why because it's the only way to keep me
out you know once we debunk the n-word
which we're going to when we get the
tapes then the company's got a big
problem when you realize you were
betrayed by your company did you pick up
the phone that you call somebody did you
do something what did you do yeah I
would talk to my confidence and my
confidence Zimmerman the Dean you know
heard Erin Thompson was there a moment
where you stormed into Papa John's
headquarters oh there was there were
some by this time there miss running the
Miss managing the company and they're
doing things that are gonna hurt people
and you've stormed into the office in
storm but I let him know that I wasn't
happy did they ever not let you in oh
yeah I've been barred from Papa John's
so was there a moment you went there and
they're like sir you can't come in no
there's moments I went there and all the
but employees when they saw me they
started crying cuz they're happy to see
me
people were crying oh yeah they know man
you got it I love people and I love
pizza I mean I love my employees they
know that so you can't ever take that
away but yeah and so the the new how
many people cried when they saw you
tears oh it was a dozens dies oh yeah
the tears were flowing yeah I remember
Kim and the corporate headquarters the
Rd Department they felt mad oh they know
what happened I mean again we come back
to the people that wake up every day
make this country great they're smart
they know exactly what's going on so
there was never this movie moment where
you went there you're like I'm coming up
and they're like sir you can't come up
well what they do is they hire lawyers
to say that you can't come up again okay
so you went up and they're like get out
you can't come back and the work what
does the lawyer say just
restraining order what does it mean well
you can't go up I don't know if they
threatened a restraining order but they
they definitely did everything they
could to keep me out of the building and
to keep me out of the stores you ever
poke them you ever show up at the stores
oh yeah yeah yeah
any good stories what's the best
provocative what's the best poke I don't
know if it's a poke it's just you know
it's when you own as many shares as I do
you want to make sure that you want to
see what's going on yeah
we ordered pizzas last week in DC and
that's the colonel colonel Freitas a
colonel who works for Papa
yeah government worker actually owns a
franchise and you know he's a he's a
pretty good operator and the the pizza
they miss you know made the pizza
supposed to be half pepperoni half meat
I mean a pepperoni half cheese so they
messed up order up pizza wasn't cooked
right it's undercooked and the employees
weren't nice to the people around me
they were rude now that would have
happened under my watch you know how can
you control on such a granular level
what goes on at a pop of junk because
it's the same machinery yeah it's the
same protocol how has the peach it
changed so dramatically you stop
measuring the matrices which we measured
quality I mean we measured how many
pepperonis how many times the phone why
would they stop doing that
because it costs money cuz there's three
reasons you stop measuring one is to
measure cost money especially when you
measure the hardest things like you know
edge lock cheese the edge is the cross
Rising 2 is you don't care don't care
what you're serving why measured in 3 is
you know it doesn't matter you know the
difference between this pizza Papa is
presenting for audio listener this is
this he has pictures of photos that he's
presenting of Pappajohn pizzas he's
presenting a 10/10 which is a beautiful
pie corresponds with the 10 points the
perfect endpoint
now the the newman's of a new leadership
through this to the wayside they got rid
of this because it's expensive but the
problem is when you train people to do
this and you don't measure thanks
better-looking this now what do you
write there 4 that's a 4 so what
we're getting we should be getting his
tens so we're getting fours now they
won't go from a 10 to a 4 overnight or
in a year but they will go from a eight
and a half pizza to a seven a half pizza
on the way to six and half pizza if you
don't measure you don't you got the
measure well now that we're on the topic
we have five Pappajohn pizzas backstage
let's bring them in and let's have you
rate each one can we do that I think so
let's bring it in Dan
and while while dance setting that up
this is gonna be fascinating I mean to
have the Papa John here they are so now
we've got five pizzas thank you Dan dan
you didn't ruin the show you were we
love you Dan we love so now here we go
so you want to just go handheld maybe
Dan or whatever so we're going to set up
the camera this is a big moment for us
so let's start here
oh yeah well yeah let's throw it to a
quick break there's a buzzing in here
too it's like really sharp we're gonna
take a quick break when we come back
we're gonna gauge pizzas with the Papa
himself so do not go away we are back
with Papa John we are about to rate the
on the scale of world is at one to ten
one to ten the quality of these five
pizzas now it's from the same store you
know what we should have done it's got
five pizzas from five different stores
because if it's a good store maybe
there's just one good employee is making
good pies it's not representative over
the whole thing but regardless of that
here we've got a cheese pizza you look
at a shot I mean that looks and that
looks clean to me
give me that rating break that down for
us okay and bring the mic up to your
mouth okay ten point perfect scale not a
bad cook cook little light plenty of
cheese mmm see the edge lock the edge
lock around the edge lock you want it
edge lock because if you don't edge lock
it when you take a bite the ingredients
to fall off how's the edge lock the edge
lock is the cheese lock
into the crust how's it here um good
better but still sloppy oh really
what's a perfect edge luck let's try
bite okay here's this mental part
there's a perfect oh just a perfect
little more cheers I've always wanted
cheers Cheers to Papa okay there's
there's a great edge lock but on the
scale to 10 that's that's borderline
eight that's servable that's servable
I'd say so
break that down the crust could be you
could rise a little more mm-hmm you want
a little bit more like a French bread
where's got the cells are different are
the pizzas just go through a machine
though how do they control the cook miss
it's called an M dog it's where you it's
how you managed the dough gonna means
the dough correctly together to react
good in the oven the oven is like a
convection oven it's really no process
dough or process hmm don't wear heat
yeah but this is a good pie that's a
good pie good pepperoncini
butter in the right place you could
serve this pizza that's that's that's
gonna be happy with that I would be
happy with that - that's the worst we
serve we're good what do you rate that
if I was really hard seven and a half
Wow if I was generous eight eight and a
half Wow
cuz he's seven a half now clean edges
right and you're looking at a tomato
sauce how do we prevent the bubbles that
unavoidable and no that's dough docking
that's the machine and then it's of
attending but if you're not measuring it
this will slip into some bad habits
right so this is not bad habits all the
way but it's it's it's it's baby
stepping away from this mm-hmm
so see that let's look at the other ones
oh yeah this is the worst we ever serve
we'd be weird oh this is and Papas being
tough here this is a seven a half I give
this up I give this a 10 I could eat the
whole thing in five seconds
okay well the minute why you do what you
do that's why I do what I do right I
mean yeah exactly I don't run a pizza
chain here now this is the funny now
this is the heart Valentine's Day pizza
were you does this predate your Houston
no no we did that product how am I
supposed to eat this there's no slice on
it
you smelled it I don't know if I've ever
seen a hot now that's a Poppaea
Ethan's Papa deal that's what that is no
I mean it's a gimmick um it's a
heart-shaped piece it's cool but you
still got to cut it we can't rate this I
don't know why they don't cut it
that's a bumper that's a Papa deal yeah
exactly I agree right where they came up
with the calzone but yeah this is fun
it's Valentine's yeah
you know it's got plenty toppings for
what it is it's fine
I agree it's I give it a ten because
it's fun
I tend for fun everybody but I don't
know why they didn't cut it yeah I mean
I don't know if they're supposed to cut
it I don't know if they're because I'm
gonna take another bite of this I'll
make sure you get on your side yeah you
don't have anything you know many
cooties anything I know one thing is
they didn't they're gonna Travis with me
too though one thing they didn't do is
put the no no that's not a time I don't
know you know Korver geniuses trying to
have it
trying to save 12 cents cost 12 cents
tinder 12 since I've it's been a while
since I've been everything you ever
think about cutting it for cost me yeah
no way you live and die by the butter
sauce on won the game that does it I
love the blue collar brother we've done
that since day one garlic butter salt
and garlic but we now have you know we
do it in mass quantities so it's a
little bit different recipe but it
tastes the way we did it from the broom
closet so today 35 years ago was that
your idea the butter we had a
independent pizzeria in New Albany next
to Jeffersonville and they put butter in
the box and I liked the concept and we
started it and people fell in love with
him when you never could stop it I'm
surprised the corporate geniuses haven't
taken the bake they might yeah they
might
I mean it's like five million bucks a
year thirty million bucks wow that's a
lot of butter a lot of
man yeah are you tuned on that oh wow so
now this is the Papa's favorite we went
back in that in the Oh John's favorite
yeah which they removed from the website
by the way oh they did yeah
I don't exist the pepperoni sausage and
six cheese yep let's break it down okay
it's a little dry
the crust didn't quite have that good
rise in it
you've got good distribution of toppings
there's a little bit of sauce on the
edge edges are not clean again we're
we're in the ballpark of 1/8 you're hot
you are a tough Pizza critic my friend
well mmm if the if it had a good rise to
it see it's a little flat because
they're not manage of the dough Cheers
wait see how flat it is right you don't
fight you're right it's good fly yeah
but you know you get the point when
you've done this millions of times where
you can kind of see if you're the pizza
god then you don't have to eat 50 pizzas
in 30 days you just need a couple bites
and you know what's going on
are you Pizza Jesus Christ are you the
savior of pizza we're gonna find out
here I fear the but if you're the pizza
Jesus Christ then Richie is Judas do you
agree the Richie's Judas he asked for
all this right right of course that's
but I actually agree you Newton you
nailed it the the crust is too thin in
and infects the I don't like the crust
major dry it's dry you want to keep that
moisture so what do you give that one
because I didn't like that one because
of the crowd I give it looks I could
almost get into an eight but again they
don't measure this the problem is it
looks great but it doesn't taste that
great Christ no longer measure the rise
come on you got to measure the rise in
the best way to measure rises as a
cheese pizza mmm so if you get the
cheese pizza right then you'll get all
the other products right but they stop
they stop this how do you measure the
rise because you cut it and then you
dissect it like surgery yeah and you see
how much that French stole look you got
and so but what affects it the dough
what happens if in the morning you go to
make you do the dough you're not getting
that rise then there's OHS out there too
green what do you do new it's not warm
enough or the oven settings are not
correct so you got a tinker
you got a tinker but we have a
management system in place to make sure
that that process happens correctly but
what gets measured gets done you know
you what you inspect is what you expect
right they stop this this is a problem
huge problem huge problem okay same
problem Wow all right see how their
plumped up here absolutely do
fundamental things in a pizza
ingredients out to the edge ingredients
in every bite no ingredients there no
ingredients there I we're getting we're
back to the desert yeah that's that one
I'm having a huge problem with this area
yeah that product that's not as bad as
theirs you know simple as some of these
other ones but you see you're on your
way Papa is you're on your way to this
with this see that's a disaster it's a
disaster me and you're getting close all
right now let's go to drive let's just
the rise this store is having a rice
problem they're not managed in the dough
and they're not means the dough goes
there not inspect that's not up there's
not up-tempo a ten-point perfect pizza
scale went out the window when I left
mmm that's our friend Richie Judas how
much don't call him Judas what's his
last name
Steve Richie Judas Richie that's not
good not good it's not good the rise is
all Wow
so if you're at home and you're not
getting this with a good rise you need
to call the store and ask for a new
pizza you think Domino's Pizza Domino's
and pizza give a guarantee why shouldn't
Papa John's no guarantee oh that's a
little better
that looks a little better that's gonna
be an eight and a half pizza at 10 well
if we got to get a little rise I mean if
we had a little rise here then we're
approaching it now with this pizza this
is gonna be a little flat too it's the
same story I mean it's the same dough
then right so this is a disaster logs
bathroom it's just
Papa John's hmm when the dough Rises and
it mixes with the sauce the when the
yeast feeds off the sugars to creat co2
when that co2 that that chemical
reaction mixes with the sauce that gives
our product that zing hmm and if you
don't if you don't have that chemical
reaction with the dough the rise you
knows anything and this place did that
happens in and the zing is the capital P
and Papa I think so yeah me too it's not
it doesn't have I think take a piece of
Wonder Bread little perfect cells and
take a good piece of French bread mmm
there's a huge difference guys one has a
good rise and one doesn't this product
it's not the recipe of the dough I don't
think they've changed that too much even
though they changed it a little bit it's
the how their mange in the dough see
there's three things that make a great
product consistency how you put the
product together ten-point scale in the
ingredients now they have changed
ingredients somewhat they got rid of the
olive oil if I'm at Pizza University
right you answer yourself a pizza
professor I mean I just know what tastes
good yeah I mean you know as my farmer
friend says the Modesto it's the food
stupid you know most people have rocks
for taste buds especially the corporate
geniuses they really don't care if it
tastes good or not all they care about
stock price you earning so they don't
really care about the people in the
product but at the end of the day you
know people that can taste the
difference you're going to pay the
difference that's our loyal customers
all right and if you get it right they
can tell the difference and they'll pay
the different eat the pizza you know
what I mean you know they're they're up
in their ivory towers and they don't eat
the pizza I think you're right
unfortunately I think you're right you
need people that that love pizza the
manager in that store is the center of
the universe the mayors are some of the
universe the center of the universe
oh they're that they're the you know the
the glue that holds it all together you
know they're the one that builds great
teams I make a great pizza and they
really make Papa John's go Wow
treasure a treat so well I mean what was
your overall impression I think the
presentation was good but there's a real
crust issue going on here it's an
epidemic I would say it's on I would say
it's the new D coronavirus of Papa
John's well you know as Ray Kroc said
your quality is only as good as your
consistency right and what you saw here
is bad habits right but they're
consistent and so you know you want to
get the point where you're doing the
right things in a very consistent way so
if there's no surprises with the
consumer but there was a lot of good
with these pizzas I agree
but if you look these product two years
ago versus 18 months versus 12 months
every six months if they don't measure
it it will continue to get worse
to the point where then your average
score is the six and then you're dead
you're dead and you're dead when you
were running everything how frequently
do you do this kind of quality control
you look great question the the how do
you measure a million pizzas a day and
the answer is you don't you measure
70,000 a year and you poll and so if you
measured enough and you incent what gets
measured gets done what gets rewarded
gets repeated so we paid bonuses on
doing this the right way and that's all
been cut out oh right so they don't get
in a bad it's like your diet or your
exercise you you don't get in the bad
habit you know in a day you're slowly
over time getting a bad habit and what
will happen if they don't measure this
then over time it'll get worse and worse
the point where you can't even recognize
a product from this now is this that no
but at least it's in the ballpark now a
few of those other pieces that I showed
you you know that's death what do you
think about Domino's at Pizza I think
they I think they do a nice job I mean I
really the business for a reason what do
you like to call them little seizures
mm-hmm I think for the the money they're
gonna value great value they use fresh
paxos a good product and that's the
thing with we were talking earlier about
no experience
I mean this is not like I mean the head
guy Papa John's he's done sandwiches
Arby's well there's no really
national roast beef chains except for
Arby's he waited Taco Bell where there's
no national chains you know do tacos but
Taco Bell
pizza you've got for big players that
are all pretty good at what they do
right and then you got another half the
market that's your independence which
are really good at guerrilla warfare so
I mean they're tough I'm going to do a
spot podcast this week with independent
called Rocco's out of New York they're
based in DC but they're come from New
York and I mean the guy's a street
fighter I mean the hoses business I mean
he's gonna get you so much more
competitive hyper-girl yeah it's it's
tough you got to be really really good
to be successful at the pizza delivery
business and you know you keep seeing
these little chinks in the armor
those little chinks are gonna add up to
the big bad chinks mm-hmm well we've
pretty much said it all Papa John we've
eaten pizza we've talked to pizza we've
talked Pizza conspiracies I mean what
what stone is left unturned what do we
what what's left is there anything you
want to add is there anything that I
should have asked you and did it I mean
there's a lot of ins and outs here is
there anything you want to say to the
people to find people of the world and
by the way I do want to say actually
just to ask you a question now that you
answer it we reached out to Papa John
years ago because we are we've sold
I like to say I sell more Papa John
pizzas and Peyton Manning I don't I
don't follow football is that the guy
who would you spin that yeah yeah I'm
Peyton's a great hockey player
[Laughter]
I've sold more pizzas than Peyton
Manning yeah my dietician was adamant on
me coming on this show you know that's
the guy back yes yeah adamant that come
on this now eight years ago and I said I
said why I had my agent at the time
reach out I says why can't we get a deal
with Papa John I'm gonna sell P I'm
gonna I'm gonna put points on that stock
but they declined but you heard of the
offer yeah I got to you yes
ah that's I wanted to do it I mean you
know it's so interesting so what
happened well
you know it's like it's like meeting
somebody and they go you know I think I
think I'm crazy I think I'm losing my
mind I just you know and then you meet
somebody says I'm not crazy you know I'm
not crazy
well the person thinks the loss of mine
they're not crazy the people that think
they're not crazy they're crazy this
self-righteous Oh John you can't go on
that show 2:11 Ethan oh my gosh you know
and we're so self-righteous our words
are perfect and our behaviors are
perfect those are the people that are
doing things behind the scenes dangerous
dangerous that their their behavior
behind the scenes was scared and strike
a raccoon but you forgot to ask me about
graduating college in three years I
totally forgot you have to I did you so
you go ahead yeah any second in my class
second from the bottom
oh really yeah I guess it Alaska in my
pocket I got a picture just to make
myself feel good and did you so didn't
you didn't finish in three years you
were finished in three years it sounds
like we finished in three years all but
one class so did you graduate I get it
second the class second from the bottom
yeah okay you got it material yeah you
brought it material prepared any other
bits you got no I appreciate you all
have delight know if dominoes ever
reached out they're like wow wow what
would you say well we're working on Wow
a lot of things in the future
the remember I love pizza I love people
whoa wait is there possibility that
there's a whoa what are you announcing
here today well we uh we always are in
search for a better pizza and we always
are when I was with Papa John's you
always gotta have better ingredients you
can't make a soap well salad Domino's
has been making some big moves in the
pizza category yeah they've killed it
the last 10 years they've done really
well you think that their will could be
a worthy Ally to you I don't know about
that we haven't talked about that I do
know that we're always in search of a
better pizza and I'm trying to end a
site for what that I mean and there's a
couple pizza areas that really make a
real
really good pizza and we're looking at
we're doing a show you can have personal
that means you you're going to invest in
them well Papa John's we always wanted
to be America's independent pizzeria
because the independents make the best
pizza there's the right throw in it
right and we were public we were a big
company but we always tried to act like
a family-run business with regards to
people and product and that's what the
independents do they have to they got to
be scrappy and they got a [ __ ] though
the food is the food stupid so we're
doing a podcast with Rocco's a pilot
this week you heard for the first time
up in DC and we're gonna we're going to
hit Rocco's pizza now they know what
they're doing this is a ground up the
best man well this is well I'm not I'm
not investing I'm just going to go in
its called pizza with Papa you know
you're making a pizza podcast with with
pizza with Papa with Rocco's pizza
that's our pilot so what is this Rocco's
pizza you see want to be a have a vested
interest in their success well we have I
love small business yes small business
is what makes America great and even as
big as Rocco makes better pizza than
Papa he makes really good pizza
ma if they keep doing this yes I do
because he's making sure this doesn't
happen in fact if you go in - Rocco's
you'll see he doesn't violate any laws
that 10 planking he gets is it like the
10 commandments like the pizza is like
the Ten Commandment but he's interesting
he's Papa if I'm reading between the
lines it sounds like you are in the
beginning of of getting behind a new
pizza empire to rival your former I see
a great battle or just Rocco's ve Papa
John
no but the shows of the show is all
about the American dream it's all about
small business and since I love pizza
what better way to go to the American
dream to America's independence and
we're going to start off with Rocco
heats it with Papa and that's going to
be fun
and then we got a few other things we're
looking at with finding a better pizza
you know always in search of a better
pizza and so the independent pizzerias
make the best pizza dr. Mary I would
doing that a TV show like Guy Fieri like
Papa Papa
we got Papa well guys a friend of mine
and Papa's not no guy you know guys
really good what he does he knows food -
he knows food really well but I know
Pizza so we're gonna have fun we're
gonna go out the entrepreneurs of
America America's independent pizzerias
good job big plan it's fun I mean he
used this I mean Rocco uses fresh back
sauce you use the Stanislas which we're
big fans of those folks he's using
grande grande cheese which is a higher
butter fat buttermilk I'll talk about
that he's using bakers pride deck of and
that's what we started in when we
started in the broom closet
you are scrappy young man with a humble
beginning you you've come to be
extremely wealthy I mean how does that
did you at what point in your career did
you become be like oh [ __ ] I'm like I'm
a wealthy guy well in the broom closet
we did $200 one night my brother and I
we're jumping up because we thought we
were rich so we've always made a good
living um no but come on there's a okay
we're gonna punch there's a difference
between like you know a couple hundred
thousand ten million dollars when we
went public in June of 93 I didn't have
five thousand dollars to take the family
on a trip really you might look what
that little and then the next day I was
worth a hundred man what was [ __ ] so
that was the day when we we did because
that was stupid money it's certain
you're 31 years old you make a hundred
million dollars you know there's no way
you know how to handle that so what
happened you go off the deep end for
everything no no you tell me I'm stay
you spent like ridiculous bought a boat
that's about a stupid yeah blow Turks
Dodge Viper thought that was cool till I
got pulled over in it but I think what's
that like to get that one Fokker the
I've never met somebody that's
successful that was arrogant and pompous
that in the short period of time became
unsuccessful
and so no matter how successful you are
you got to stay gracious you got to stay
Thanks come on humble and when you make
a hundred million bucks at thirty-one
you know you you got to have some people
around you to do some pruning to make
sure you don't think you're as smart as
you think you are and so you know was it
bad no but could have been better
yeah but they don't write a book on this
crap you better do that was that cash
you just got cash yeah it's just cat
just straight to your bank account
no cash and stock stock so let's say
it's go over 80 million in stock and 20
million cash nothing with that money
probably buy a house buy yeah yeah and
then but something like a money in the
stock market or the money like a money
market account yeah you try to buy
property how yes you know you buy some
Warren Buffett you know some folks know
with what about your family and friends
were they like whoa this guy's like do
people act differently I mean that
always happens doesn't it you know the
friends really the family is it really
that doesn't change them they're pretty
grounded because that's just you know to
respect the people to make this country
great is in making their lives better I
mean that's that's really the key to
happiness that's how I get fulfilled you
find yourself withdrawn though as you
become because it's almost like it's
hard to relate to other people when you
come that wealthy right do you find
yourself withdrawn more no no I don't
have a problem I mean I actually relate
better to a waiter in a restaurant or
somebody that's driving them you know
truck then I do a governor I do much
better with people that work for a
living and are scrappy then I do with
people that are wealthy I can do both
but you know I can have that repertory
but I'd much rather be with somebody
that's I'd rather be with Rocco's pizza
next week then people then with the vice
president and I like the vice president
he's fine I would wonder with him who
would you try to be with Rocco dude once
you get a good pile Mike Pence doesn't
seem like a lot of fun but I don't know
how long do you take you to come up with
the Ten Commandments dear
and enlightening one day there is very
perfect yeah we had this from the get-go
you know but over the years you get
research and research refines little
things like we always had an edge lock
but we didn't call it that and we always
tried to get the ingredients out to the
edge just distracting here though no I
think it's great I got I'm just trying
that I called me a woman you say it
sucks man he's a little um what did you
call it the crust issue then rise it has
a rise issue that's all but you ever get
had good on the street from people never
we haven't had one incident out in
public about this wow that's what I say
a lot of what la vez was fabricated by
the the Papa John's in the board which
is very difficult when your own company
starts making things up and creates a
narrative that's false why why did the
NFL guy I hate like why why did he have
it just taste for you cuz I was on this
case to fix the problem listen that's
what leaders do they fix the problem
what do you mind explaining a little bit
about that issue cuz we didn't really
talk about it but like what do you mean
by saying that you were just on him to
fix the problem
okay our largest bin was the NFL it was
some forty million bucks we're huge how
much 40 million 40 million the year
givers close to Pizza sponsor yeah
official pizza of NFL that's you um and
the ratings were all twenty percent
because of the Nealon controversy so
there was less ratings less people
watching and you were paying the same
amount right
I see take a 20 percent decrease in
ratings on 40 mil how much is that it's
an eight million dollar loss so our
being the fourth in the category we
don't really have the sustainability to
cover an eight million dollar deficit so
my marching orders to Goodell was fix
this to the players and owners
satisfaction he didn't like that he
didn't like that long in fact I don't
even ever say stop the players from
kneeling no of course not
because the headline that I consumed and
always saw was that Papa John doesn't
want the
kneeling as if you were taking a
political stance against that no no way
so how did that get out I think the
company promoted that to pop it on from
even back then was November I think
Shapiro and Richie by that time we're
like if we don't say anything and let
the media you know crucify him then we
can advance to take over who got the
story who like cuz they got the story
wrong who originally told them it was
Papa John doesn't want the players
kneeling the comments were 10 after
10:00 on a Wednesday and by within an
hour they changed it from fix the
problem here Roger that's his bad
leadership fix it to the players and
owners satisfaction to kneeling to race
and less than one iron and went viral so
it was premeditated they were sitting on
the comments well why don't will is it a
far is it a stretch of the imagination
to think that fix the problem means get
them to stop kneeling no because I think
they can deal I think they just have to
do in a way that doesn't polarize the
situation again I'm not gonna tell him
to kneel or not you just were look I
just went online I just want to resolved
yeah because you're and they did get a
result the the following year but it had
gone on too long but from a from a from
a business owner sample and I can
certainly see where you're coming from I
mean you're paying 40 million bucks and
now you're getting less eyeballs oh yeah
it was you know when you know you have
to understand eighty percent of the
money's going to the NFL are the small
business owners the Papa John's called
called the franchisees so we're expected
to be good stewards of their money and
so when we're spending forty man and
we're getting a 20% discount on our
spend then it's my job as a CEO and a
publicly held company to say hey we got
it we got to resolve this we need well
we need to get this dinner that makes a
lot of sense and you feel that he had
there were options for him to fix it and
like what could he do he did fix it here
yeah I'm not exactly sure how you fixed
it but he did fix it within 10 months
they'd been kneeling didn't there I
think they took the kneeling pregame o
or they put a penalty they did something
but they resolve the issue sorry I just
took a huge slice of the huge banner
did this all it seems
let me just chew my food it's good pizza
just as fries it's my recipe it better
be good it seems that this whole
conspiracy started or the first time I
saw you and controversy was Obamacare
Affordable Care Act when you said you
opposed and correct me if I'm wrong you
you oppose the Affordable Care Act
because it rise increased the cost of
pizzas by 12 cents or something of that
nature
no the analyst worried about the cost of
Obamacare our delivery charge per Pete's
is about 250 260 a PI Obamacare was 14
cents so the point was it's
insignificant it's not a problem
I mean it's less than 20 percent of what
it costs to deliver the pizza
so it was an analogy to explain that 14
cents of Pizza because there is a cost I
mean you know when you provide more
health care there's a cost but it's it's
insignificant on because you on it on
$11 Pizza 14 cents just over you know
over a point so it's not a problem but
your comment was that you were gonna
lower employees hours to avoid paying
their health insurance a that I will say
in Hawaii there's a franchisee out there
where they had a program similar to
Obamacare and that's what he did he
lowered the hours
that's what end up happening with a lot
of the companies in the market but I
never said that
so you are saying that that you your
comment was in support of Obamacare and
not against as it sounds like you like
you're saying it was 13 cents and that
that's a small amount so who cares but
at the time it was reported in what I've
read is that you were saying that it was
going to be an undue cost no I'm paying
the my comments were the 14 cents is
incidental
it doesn't matter and that it's good
that everybody's going to have health
insurance you know because if we did it
everybody else had to do it so we looked
at it as a good thing if as long as
everybody did it you know as one so we
didn't if you look at the speech I gave
it Edison we looked at it as a very good
thing that a hundred percent of
employees were gonna have health
insurance
hmm that's
interesting there's the transcript
totally not how it was reported but
remember what I told you when this
wasn't mm well it was a long November
the 2nd of 2012 would the company do
nothing what happens when the company
does nothing John gets hurt mm-hmm by
November first of 17 they did it again
they did nothing I got killed and they
painted in the race so now the company
now has a track record of knowing when
they don't do nothing it hurts me and if
you're wanting to take me out of the
picture what better way to do it then
ignore what was really said hmm
and of course but you are saying just
for the record that you never said that
your lower employees hours no I'd say
there's a here's the beautiful thing is
the there's a tape from Edison College
on that speech which is you can get that
tape if you want to see it I'll send it
to you and ela the transcript 2017 is a
transcript there's a tape and there's a
tape on the laundry service so there's a
tape on all three comments and none of
the comments are indicative of what was
reported by the media and Papa John's
did nothing to clear the record now is
that good what turned out to be a
disaster mm-hmm so if you take the
position we're going to get rid of the
founder and we're going to violate the
duty of care and the duty of loyalty and
we're going to throw him on the bus
under the bus for something you didn't
say probably not legal
probably not cool but they're making a
bet that the company would be better
without me right it's turned out to be a
disaster the company's in trouble the
franchisees in trouble so not only did
they violate the law not only to do
something it was borderline evil they've
heard a lot of people on the way what
would you say - I imagine what they
would say in response to that is that
the company was already on the decline
because of your actions I would say that
the company was on the decline because
they didn't crack the record and they
meant let what was mischaracterize
carried on and they further embellished
it remember the two people in charge of
PR that were supposed to protect me
deserted me and call you in the middle
of that now I've made these people multi
mainers not one executive one board
member is called and said how you
hmm probably ordered not to communicate
with you I don't know what it is but can
you imagine a founder building 5000
tours of a broom closet and having
something miscarriage over your family
they had them over the house at
Christmas took them on trips and they
don't even call to check out and how
you're doing now there's some people
that are feels bad
they're pretty sad that's pretty sad
yeah I feel sorry for people that I mean
when you build a 5,000 store chain out
of a broom closet and you make all these
people multi-millionaires and you know
you have something like this happen it's
untruthful and not fair and it's not
right in the sense that that's not my
character that's not my moral fiber and
yet they don't pick up the phone and say
hey where's a disagreement here but how
you doing how's your family personal
resentment it sounds like yeah you
expected more from these people how do
you people that yeah people that you
think are put together you know these
are leaders of the community they put
together very well you know they're not
put together the way they pretend to be
put together in the corporate geniuses
please do you have trouble trusting
people no no but you get better at it
you're more guarded you're more you're
more you are you have to be you have to
be more retreated now and guarded of who
you speak to and who you associate with
yeah there's got to be trauma there PTSD
yeah potentially the member that you
have to look at things of what did I do
wrong
what could I have done better and a
couple things one is 31% didn't hold the
day it just would so I should have you
only 31 percent you thought that would
be enough I thought it'd be how did it
end up not being enough because what
happened though that 31 wasn't enough to
carry another 20 percent against what
would the backlash on the inward so
everybody all the other owners colluded
to for a community community 51% to oust
you the board source of that the board
colluded with the media to make the
n-word worse than it was and then went
to the other owners and said we have a
bad apple in John that's kind of how
they did that the second thing is is
remember I knew this something like this
could happen but not from people around
me that I cared about because it wasn't
in their best
to do this right to your point the the
lesson there is you have to have a you
have to have your guard up a little
better but I missed the boat on those
two aspects and I lost my company and
the company now is in trouble well I was
gonna ask you know in summary looking
over though the story as it is you've
got these three big media controversies
dating back first time I heard you in
the news in that regard was 2012 with
the favorable Court Care Act which
according to you was misreported what's
the story in all of this for you what do
you take away from this whole from this
whole experience you've build it up in
2012 then in the past couple of years
again two more controversies with the
kneeling and then that phone call where
you said the N word like what's the what
do we I mean what's what how do you
what's the story you know what's the
lesson for you I think the the lesson is
you always go through things like this
and you come out beside other side a
better person and this this makes you
stronger and better and it makes you
more appreciative the people that do
good and do have a good good soul the we
had a really good thing going it was
making 150 million bucks a year and we
had the best pizza and that service and
everybody's making a lot of money so
that introduces an element of being
comfortable and sometimes when you're
comfortable you don't you know you don't
prune the bad parts of yourself as much
as you should
whereas if you go through something like
this it forces you to be a better person
in every way and I could have never sold
eight million shares the stock when in
the position I was a CEO because it
would scare derails to death these folks
have come in they've created a mirage
and they created a forest they bump the
stock up to 65 and I've been able to
sell 70 means I'm kind of a nice thing
it's a real nice thing because I never
would have been able to sell seven eight
millions years without silver lining
yeah you cashed out a little bit we're
right before you cut it right plus now I
get me do the math would you sell how
many seriously so let's say eight mil
eight million shares my god and that
what and I what value let's just do 50
for math it's 400 mil
so you cashed out 400 million and how do
you feel I told you I'll be okay that
work so the company pays you four
hundred million dollars people to buy in
the stock paid the form and then this
guy is coming in and saving the company
with how much 250 mil and you [ __ ] but
you just sucked out 400 million let's
see who's right Oh somebody's again he's
got this thing sold so what did they
expect they knew you were gonna sell
your stock you'd be kind of be silly of
you not to sell well here's what I was
hoping I was hoping they could run it
better than I could run it I really was
I mean I let's see let's see I mean
because I you think maybe you don't know
as much you let tell maybe they're right
maybe the right and yeah so four o'clock
along here at three or four percent
comps and we're making good pizza and
culture and everybody's getting raises
I'm like well it's not how I would have
done it but good for them
but that's not what's happened you know
we're closing stores I went down to my
hometown store in Park City yesterday to
get it the Papa Diaz early Papa's owns
but Papa D is okay and the stores closed
I had to drive all the way to Salt Lake
but closing stores people losing their
jobs and so I can't be part of that and
I don't want to be part of it but the
silver lining is now I'm involved with
some some health things I love people I
love pizza and we've found some things
that really can help people's health
make people feel better emotionally
spiritually and intellectually and
physically that turns me on
you got 400 million dollars in the bank
you could do whatever the hell you want
damn that's more than good to Papa it's
been a blessing from God told you make
you a religious man not religious but
there's definitely a higher power oh for
sure I was just wondering if faith has
been at played a role in your life at
all or helped you through this
yeah when you've had your teeth kicked
in like this it puts you on your knees
pretty quickly which is a good thing it
makes you know number oh my gosh I mean
you you know when you get your noggin
knocked around like this on something
you really didn't say or do you you get
you know I was always spiritual anyway
because I never
- how the speed of light 186,000 miles a
second you know mother nature I mean I
just find all that like way above my
intellectual oh great yeah but this will
this will make you you know this will
make you humble in a lot of ways so have
you heard the term that are I sent our
fans use a lot Papa bless Papa bless ya
I hope that all thank you here and
before we reached out or connect and got
connected I heard it but I don't know
what met ya it's just a weird thing I
really don't even know how it started
but it's so prolific now everybody says
Papa bus which is a reference to you of
course so meant we've all been praying
for you this whole time all these years
it worked
I guess it's it working I mean we got
Rocco's Rocco's we got another couple
I've got another I got another couple
peace of places I'm working on I can't
wait to share with you fun and then we
got this health thing going on how many
stocks it how many shares you have left
and Papa John two mill three will damn
you are a very wealthy man Jesus Papa we
took we took the company over and when
are you billion does that make you and
that makes you close closer to the
billion than 500 million but that's no
Civ Club it's a blessing and you can do
so much good with those resources and I
plan on doing that
but we're having fun with people's
health and we're having fun with
independent pizzerias we're out the
father-son pizza we're out to find a
better way to go through life to help
other people
why don't you sell the rest of your
stock what's holding on to it well you
you there's laws
oh so you can only do so much at a time
so you would offload all of it and just
move on if you could I don't know if I
would do that I can't really say that
because I don't know if that would that
would that would do to the stock if I
said that but it sounds like you're
saying here that you're suggesting in a
in in an indirect way that people should
sell their stock what I'm suggesting is
everything I did from ona bring out the
ten point baby to seventeen to take the
stock from 650 share to $89 every single
fundamental thing we did our principles
our values our people our interpersonal
relationships the printables are gone
they're violating and also the company
is in financial it's being floated by
this
investment so it sounds like they've
artificially inflated the price of the
stock I mean now is the time to get out
if you got Papa John stock it sounds
like yeah the two metaphors that I've
use is even if you love the car you
don't need to be in the car when the car
crashes right and the other one is in my
opinion the ship has already hit the
iceberg it's already Lisbon but they got
a camera that makes it look like it's
level it's a farce let's see what
happens it's got a break here by the way
I hope I'm wrong
yeah I think you got a lot of money
invested Oh God hope he returns for two
years and I've been ranting and raving
and telling them you know this is a
losing proposition
and they're probably tired of me telling
that for two years I hope that was wrong
you still have a hundred million dollars
in that company and stock value at fifty
dollars at 65 bucks is a little more o
65 let me recalculate excuse me it's 130
but keep going do you or have you ever
watched something like Kitchen
Nightmares no you don't like that it's
good [ __ ] check it out good you watch TV
you watch food shows most mostly sports
sports sports guy that must have been a
real honor for you to get involved with
that and it felt like a dream yeah that
was lucky cuz I saw you what goes with
those players all smiles and you're an
all on the field and doing all that I
mean that must have been amazing yeah
Peyton was great Montana was great
marina was great I mean JJ Watt was
great we had a lot of fun without Jerry
Jones the bus Jerome he was great you
know
Shaq's been great yeah Popish attack
copy I wanted to ask you about publish
Shaq we're not just having a fan of Shaq
well everybody's a yeah everyone like
Joe yeah we just got Farah what numbers
gonna work 34 36 are you know but but
don't was the Shaq deal facilitated that
was after you were ousted right yeah I
had nothing so is that a shame that
you're like damn I like Shaq I wish we
could hang out absolutely I mean you
ever talk to him no I've never talked to
Shawn I'm a big Shaq fan Jack sits on
the board but well I'm not as close to
Shaq as I was Peyton right gtalk do you
talk to them I talked to Peyton you know
and those guys
on a need-to-know basis until I get this
controversy resolved because I can't
live that's a liability for them and I
can't put them in that position right
and I haven't yeah but yeah what a
complicated life you live it's a shame
you never got to serve on the board the
same time as Shaq right that would have
been interesting yeah I know Shaq here's
where Shaq and I agree with Papa John's
he wants to use his voice and the guys
that are bees want to use the different
voice like they did at Arby's I think
they should use Shaq's voice I really
did I mean if you're gonna he's gonna be
your spokesperson yeah is the only using
10-15 percent of the ads that's where
Shaq it's real where did you really get
him in there folks were some put it in
there and use his voice but I agree with
Shaq on those two those two issues but
thank you all for having me thank you
thank you for coming joy as a pleasure
was a marathon who went for a while how
long we went no two and a half hours Wow
[Laughter]
well let's see you might owe me I'll be
back yeah I'll be back as the as the CEO
and founder of the world of the newest
and biggest piece of chain Rocco's mama
mama bless all of us yeah well thank you
Papa John it's been a privilege it's
been an honor it's been a dream
fulfilled come to fruition eight years
eight years in the making baby you like
it thank you so much thank you guys
we'll see you on Wednesday with
PewDiePie so we'll see you then or well
on Thursday but anyway guys have a great
God have a Papa boss
[Music]